[Música]
este miércoles pasaban de 41.000 los
fallecidos por los terremotos que
sacudieron Turquía y Siria hace más de
una semana la policía turca arrestó a 78
personas acusadas de crear pánico con lo
que llamaron publicaciones provocativas
en redes sociales entre tanto en Siria
se sigue denunciando la falta de ayuda
humanitaria
la justicia nicaragüense retiró la
nacionalidad a otras 94 personas entre
ellas los escritores Sergio Ramírez y
Gioconda belli el ex comandante de la
Revolución Luis Carrión el periodista
Carlos Fernando Chamorro se les acusa de
delitos considerados como traición a la
patria a consecuencia también se les
incautarán todos los bienes a favor del
estado
en Colombia la oposición al gobierno de
Gustavo Petro marchó este miércoles por
las principales ciudades del país esto
luego que el martes fuera el gobierno
quien convocará marchas en su apoyo las
protestas llegan como respuesta a tres
reformas clave para el nuevo gobierno
colombiano de izquierdas a las leyes
laborales a las pensiones y al sistema
de salud Tenemos reporte
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias sobre los terremotos en Turquía
y Siria y al continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos empezamos con las noticias
de Turquía y Siria donde continúan las
labores de rescate y cada vez son menos
las personas que están siendo
encontradas con vida la cifra de Muertos
superaba este miércoles los 41.000
también el miércoles en territorio Turco
los equipos de rescate lograron hallar
al menos cinco sobrevivientes tras nueve
días atrapados bajo los escombros el
gobierno inició procedimientos legales
contra casi 300 personas de las cuales
ya detuvo a 78 acusadas de crear pánico
con publicaciones provocativas en redes
sociales y las autoridades planean la
demolición de hasta 50.000 edificios en
el sureste del país Mientras tanto en
Siria el grupo de rescate conocido como
cascos blancos en el noreste del país
dijo que la ayuda humanitaria tarda en
llegar sus habitantes denuncian la falta
de suministros y elementos necesarios
para socorrer a Los afectados a pesar de
que tres pasos fronterizos humanitarios
han sido ya abiertos la ONU asegura que
la situación sigue siendo crítica
queremos que nuestra voz llegue a todo
el mundo Pero dónde está la ayuda hay
cientos de personas que todavía
necesitan carpas y ni siquiera tienen
donde sentarse búsquenos una solución De
dónde vendrá esta ayuda ya veremos la
ayuda nunca va a llegar aquí
y otras 94 personas fueron despojadas de
su nacionalidad en Nicaragua entre ellas
los escritores Sergio Ramírez y Gioconda
belli el ex comandante de la Revolución
Luis Carrión y el periodista Carlos
Fernando Chamorro la sentencia del
tribunal de apelaciones de Managua los
acusó a todos de a todos ellos de
delitos considerados como traición a la
patria además decretó la incautación a
favor del Estado nicaragüense de todos
los bienes inmuebles y sociedades de los
procesados esto luego que el jueves Más
de 200 opositores al gobierno de Daniel
Ortega fueran desterrados a Estados
Unidos un paso que Washington calificó
como constructivo para hacer frente a
los abusos de los Derechos Humanos en
Nicaragua
ordenese la pérdida de la nacionalidad
nicaragüense de todo los acusados
ténganse a lo acusados como traidores a
la patria por lo que se les impone las
penas accesorias de inhabilitación
absoluta y especial para ejercer cargos
públicos
ejercer la función pública En nombre o
al Servicio
del Estado de Nicaragua
así como ejercer cargos de elección
popular y la pérdida de sus derechos
ciudadanos de forma perpetua
respectivamente
en Colombia la oposición al gobierno de
Gustavo Petro marcho este miércoles por
las principales ciudades del país esto
luego que el martes fuera el gobierno
quien convocará marchas en su apoyo las
protestas llegaron como respuesta a tres
reformas clave para el nuevo gobierno
colombiano de izquierda a las leyes
laborales a las pensiones y al sistema
de salud anteriormente en el marco de
nuestro programa directo a América
edición nocturna nuestro compañero Luis
Muñoz nos comentaba la perspectiva
política a la que se enfrenta el
gobierno de Petro con esta reformas
son estas tres reformas sociales que
comentábamos y la primera la más
importante con la que ha tenido más
prisa Gustavo Petro es la reforma a la
salud que fue radicada el lunes en el
congreso y que tendrá que ser aprobada
por este mismo congreso por los
congresistas tanto en la cámara de
representantes como en el senado y esta
reforma la salud lo que pretende es un
aumento de la atención primaria pero
también pasaron un sistema un modelo que
tenga una mayor un mayor peso lo público
después vendrán otras dos reformas que
también tuvieron espacio en su discurso
ayer en la plaza pública y en la Plaza
de Armas en su residencia y son la
laboral y la pensional que todavía no
conocemos el texto por lo que sí que
estamos viendo Es que Gustavo Petro en
este primer año que todavía no ha
llegado quiere llevar adelante las
grandes reformas de lo que será su
gobierno como ya fue también la reforma
tributaria con la que aumentó en 4.000
millones de dólares el presupuesto anual
y también pues además de las sociales
también habrá espacio para forma a la
justicia Y es que también próximamente
el gobierno de Gustavo Petro quiere
sacar adelante la ley del sometimiento
que le permita hacer negociaciones
colectivas con bandas armadas que se
dediquen al Crimen y al narcotráfico Y
es que sí que está pudiendo negociar ya
con bandas armadas que tienen un origen
político como es el ejército de
liberación nacional la guerrilla activan
más antigua de América Latina
Bolivia lucha contra un fuerte brote de
dengue que ha colapsado los hospitales
del país especialmente en la región de
Santa Cruz la más grande del país niños
y adolescentes están siendo los más
afectados por este brote que deja Ya al
menos 26 fallecidos y
6.845 casos según la agencia boliviana
de noticias Abby el gobierno central y
el de la región de Santa Cruz apartaron
temporalmente a sus discrepancias para
erradicar conjuntamente el fin de semana
casi un millón de criaderos de los
mosquitos que transmiten esta enfermedad
Y este 15 de febrero se cumplió un año
de la tragedia que sufrió la ciudad
brasileña de petrópolis las peores
lluvias de su historia dejaron 235
muertos más de 4.000 desplazados y
15.000 afectados desde entonces muchos
de ellos estos necesitan ayuda para
alimentarse el reportes de nuestra
corresponsal Valeria saccone
[Aplausos]
aquel fatídico 15 de febrero
impetrópolis Y llovió impresoras más de
lo que se esperaba para todo el mes los
deslizamientos dejaron 235 muertos
desde entonces la ong sos Serra ayuda a
las familias necesitadas entregando un
millar de canastas solidarias por mes
en estas canastas hay arroz frijoles
aceite harina de yuca harina de maíz
pasta normalmente para una familia de
cuatro personas alcanza un mes
hoy Carolina lleva las provisiones a
cara Flora una comunidad que fue
totalmente devastada por las lluvias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en este barrio encaramado en la montaña
23 personas perdieron la vida
el rastro de la destrucción todavía Es
evidente en una ciudad donde el 30% de
los habitantes vive en áreas de riesgo
por la falta Crónica de vivienda
esta mujer perdió a seis miembros de su
familia dispuesto callejero de comida
mi mayor problema ahora es el trabajo Yo
me esfuerzo trabajo como limpiadora hago
pequeños trabajos estoy consiguiendo
sobrevivir
desde estas pantallas la protección
civil controla si los ríos se desbordan
el ayuntamiento ha creado un protocolo
de evacuación ante la imposibilidad de
realojar a todos los vecinos en riesgo
toda
la población tiene que ser entrenada
este es nuestro mayor desafío
paralelamente a las obras públicas
los expertos coinciden en que esta
tragedia es un reflejo del cambio
climático y que puede repetirse
petrópolis lucha para recuperar la
normalidad
al menos un muerto y tres heridos de un
nuevo tiroteo en un centro comercial de
la ciudad estadounidense del paso en la
frontera con México así lo confirmó la
policía de la urbe quien también informó
que detuvieron a un presunto sospechoso
Sin dar más detalles del presunto motivo
del ataque ni del estado de los heridos
el centro comercial se encuentra junto a
un almacén Walmart en donde en 2019 otro
tiroteo dejó 23 muertos
y terminamos con una triste noticia del
cine falleció Raquel welles actriz
estadounidense y símbolos sexual de las
décadas de los 60 y 70 la mujer murió a
los 82 años según confirmó su hijo Demon
welles Solo que se conoce sólo se conoce
que falleció en su casa en Los Ángeles y
la familia no dio detalles de la causa
de la muerte algunos de los papeles más
recordados de Raquel welles son los que
hizo la película de ciencia ficción
Fantastic en 1996 y en el drama un
millón de años antes de Cristo
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
[Música]